le cinéma maintenant en croire Nour bous
cinéaste tunisien et réalisateur de
business le dialogue entre l'Orient et
l'Occident passe surtout l'été par le
sexe d'ailleurs ceux qui le pratiquent
avec les touristes ont un alibi seul un
business est en mesure de financer son
départ pour l'étranger mais ce sujet
n'est que la morce d'un plus vaste débat
que Nour B nous propose sous la forme
donc d'une comédie
[Musique]
deur bonjour bonjour J'ai reçu cette
lettre d'une amie et je ne sais pas
lire ça ne vous dérangerait pas de le
faire
non Roufa mon
chéri c'est
grave des hommes qui font l'amour comme
toi je n'en ai pas connu
ici je peux te rendre folle je suis un
pr à conquérir le
monde très
belle
[Musique]
tranqus
alors Henri Chapier il y a quand même
dans ce film le procès d'un d'un
néocolonialisme estival dont les
occidentaux doivent assumer la
responsabilité oui c'est un peu vrai
évidemment parce que dans un pays comme
la Tunisie on le sait la vie est
difficile le franc est plus fort que le
dinar et évidemment on en profite
involontairement mais à tous les niveaux
pas
uniquement sur ce point-là c'est vrai
aussi qu'en général on peut considérer
que ces vacances
estivales les Occidentaux en profitent
partout dans ces pays c'est un peu
injuste c'est vrai mais disons que pour
ce qui est de ce sujet là il y a aussi
et d'ailleurs vous ne le cache pas une
petite responsabilité sur place une
certaine complaisance une certaine un
accommodement avec le ciel on en parlera
alors justement nor bous vous avez été
emprisonné pendant 6 ans de 1973 à 1979
dans votre pays pour délit d'opinion ne
va-t-on pas vous reprocher finalement
avec ce
film de dénigrer aujourd'hui la Tunisie
euh déjà c'est une très vieille histoire
et le film se d'abord je pose pas un
regard moral j'essaie de montrer quelque
chose qui est caché que que le le public
français par exemple que le public
tunisien ne connaît pas très bien euh en
quelque sorte lev un peu le voile sur la
société euh mais il faut pas dramatiser
c'està-dire ça c'est un petit quotidien
qui existe qui se passe sans violence
mais
qui que j'aimerais montrer euh parce que
ça fait partie d'un vécu d'ailleurs la
dernière scène là qu'on vient de voir
est assez significative puisque votre
héros pratique on appelle ça un gigolo
bien sur business en français mais à la
fin lorsque Jacques penau le photographe
qui rêve de portrait de femme idéale dit
écoute ta femme est superbe alors là il
manque de mourir en revanche donc il y a
deux espèces de morale c'est-à-dire
qu'on touche pas à la femme d'un
tunisienel la tradition aussi c'est
c'est aussi montrer un peu la condition
de la femme à travers ce problème aussi
euh ça c'était pour moi euh disons que
les rapports avec le tourisme tout ça
c'est un prétexte pour montrer aussi
cette condition dans laquelle se trouve
une femme affrontée à ce problème la
femme de ce business mais votre film a
été bien accueilli en Tunisie par il n
pas encore sorti il n'est pas encore
sorti mais je pense qu'il sera très bien
accueilli parce que il leur parle de
quelque chose qu'il qu'ils connaissent
mais là je j'aimerais
disons toucher le public français et
justeement comment voyez-vous l'avenir
de cette jeunesse justement parce que
pour elle l'Occident est un eldorado et
on sait que ça finit toujours assez mal
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire pour que
cette mythologie s'arrête à VII
euh je crois que ça va pas s'arrêter je
pense que ça peut continuer il faut
l'apprendre avec plus de sourire avec le
plaisir et euh il faut pas en dramatiser
euh je crois que ça c'est la vie et dans
le film ça continue avec le l'enfant et
c'est une histoire qui ne peut pas
s'arrêter parce que si on veut poser les
choses en terme de morale là euh on va
se tromper on va faire euh à mon avis
des choses pas bien merci Nour bouside
je rappelle donc letre de votre film
business qui sort sur vos écrans en
France